hey everyone I'm Ilana and welcome it to
my channel after just over three years
since I got my job offer I am a leaving
IGN
June 29th is going to be my last day
that's this Friday depending on when
you're watching this and I just wanted
to say thank you so much to everyone
that I worked with and thank you so much
to everyone who watched the content that
I created on IGN of the past three years
a lot of the stuff that I didn't really
do feel like family and there are so
many people there doing so many
different things that I just genuinely
really love as humans it's honestly just
really hard to leave that and I know
that everyone who works at IGN says they
miss the people more than anything [ __ ]
I'm gonna miss you guys so much so to
those people just thank you for
welcoming me and for watching alongside
me and I'm just so wonderful and I just
wish that the public can you how
wonderful you all really are and of
course to the people who watched me on
IGN thank you to those who said kind
things are engaged in discussions or
giving me feedback
trust me I noticed you and thank you so
much I feel like I've grown a lot in a
lot of ways while working at IGN and
that would have been a genuine struggle
without all of your support please keep
spreading a positivity to everyone who
walks in IG and there's so many people
in that building who work so so hard in
ways that you wouldn't even realize but
hey thank you for listening to me talk
about things I was passionate about for
such a long time I got a little on a
crazy [ __ ] that I still can't even
really comprehend while I worked at IGN
and I'm still just in disbelief that
I've been able to do a lot of stuff that
I have done over the past three years
like 10 year old on would have freaked
out so thank you for supporting me
through what was a literal dream come
true so as for why I'm leaving this
incredible place with these incredible
people I there are a lot of reasons
honestly
but I don't really want this video to be
about that I feel like I should be most
celebratory right now I'm more thankful
so the biggest reason I'll give you that
I think the biggest reason is just that
I'm very ambitious this is the same
reason that I left everyone I had ever
known and my entire family in Australia
so this is kind of on brand for me at
this point it honestly probably would
have been easier for me to stay there
and stick to what I know and and stick
to what I've gotten used to but I don't
think that that as much that's scarier
than feeling stagnant and I'll be honest
I did I felt I felt stuck I felt like I
didn't have a lot of career progression
like I wasn't really growing anymore I
don't think you grow as applausing
without making changes and taking risks
but in the time I was that I did one so
much and I wore so many hats and that
experience was genuinely priceless so
now I do want to mention that I am going
to another company
I'm not going independent I figured a
lot of people would wonder about that
but I am going to another company
everyone else where I'm going in a
little bit but stay tuned for that but
they all changes that are going to be
made to some of the stuff that I do
outside of work too including this
YouTube channel the first thing is that
I'm shutting down patreon
of course everyone a patron already
knows about this I told them as soon as
I could and the video that I put up at
the end of May was really my way of
trying to publicly tell everyone how
much I valued patreon and how important
those people are to me but I will also
admit that it's going to be very nice to
have a job where I can afford to pay
rent without having to rely on a service
like that like I did at IGN so one other
change that I'm very excited about that
I hope all of you will be excited about
is that since I'm no longer on the ideas
previous content restrictions I'm a lot
of stop doing Let's Plays and streams
and [ __ ] I don't know if you've been
paying attention but the lost let's play
that I posted was literally the day
before I started working in IGN aside
from one charity video that I did this
year that admittedly as soon as I all
said June if I could do it they were
100% like absolutely you can use our
equipment if you want to
they were very open to be doing that but
as soon as this change happens I'm able
to start talking about games more on
this channel some people in the comments
on that cyberpunk video were like are
you not allowed to make this while
working at IGN and I was like yeah I
totally broke the rules to make this
video which was obviously because I knew
I would be leaving
sorry about that IGN but I'm excited to
be able to do stuff like that here again
my channel really slowed down in terms
of growth as soon as I started working
at IGN so in little games Sonya should
be cool and aside from that I figured
I'd do a sort of IGN QA so feel free to
ask any questions in the comments below
and I will answer so I think that's
pretty much it I feel like I've done a
good job of saying contained here but it
will be my last episode of beyond this
week my last episode of unlocked imagine
it's going to be a pretty emotional week
but on that note we are actually this
wasn't planned we are actually doing a
live beyond on the 29th so the last day
that I will walk there meaning that fans
can come into the office on my last day
I'll leave a link below to where you can
get tickets for that and there are still
some available if you want to come say
hi and check out the office at my loss
and you could totally do that
I am also DJing it kind of funny prom
this weekend which is going to be pretty
exciting but really man I know that this
period of my life will stay with me
forever
it sort of feels like a part of my
identity at this point and that's why
it's so we had to leave
I am also incredibly excited about some
of the new opportunities coming my way
and I think a lot of you will be really
excited to we'll be doing similar but
also very different stuff and I think
that a lot of you are really really
going to like it you will still get to
see my face a bunch but I'm gonna be
able to do a lot more creative stuff
I'll be working with a team of people
who are all working towards one goal
whereas IGN
my role is a little bit isolated I work
on projects almost by myself sometimes
which it's going to be nice to work on
things as part of a team with a place
that I think will be very very
supportive of that and I hope you guys
will join me I really do think a lot of
you are going to be very happy about it
and I mean even on a base level I think
it's gonna be a lot better for my mental
health like I'm sure you guys have
noticed how often I talk about being
exhausted and tie-in and traveling all
the time and I think that um I'm
probably gonna be a little bit more of a
positive person like as a whole as a
result of the different kind of stuff
that I'll be doing but I want to say
that I will also be doing all of the
stuff that I'm doing now that's why it
feels like kind of a win-win is like I
still get to do literally pretty much
everything I'm working on right now and
as well as other stuff very big because
we haven't made any announcements yet
but I'm excited to share it with you all
and I yeah I I hope that you guys are
excited too so I think that's it wish me
luck tomorrow for the morning if you've
seen this video I'm Alana and I will see
you guys next time
Oh